so I'll read
out the sub commmittee decided that the
application to review was a valid
application having heard from all the
parties and carefully listened to all
the evidence and read the paperwork
including the
supplement issued by both sides we
mindful of the guidance issued the
licing ACT 2003 and also that any steps
taken have to be fair and proportionate
promotion of the licensing object
objectives having heard the committee
feel
that
objectiv have to be protected that is in
our mind however we feel re revocation
is disproportionate in this case so
we're going to
not allow the license to continue with
the uh
modification to following conditions so
looking at the conditions we've gone for
column one I think most of it been agre
anyway for column one
except for
4.2
4.4.7 which are called
to
4.9.4 column 2 and Al
4.98
point2 column 2
also on page 171 of the report we're
going to remove the suggested conditions
4.9
12.7
4.9.2
um
4.9.1 12.9 171 to adop column
two
4103 page
173 we're also going to adopt the AMG
suggestion on column two but apart from
those seven exceptions we're going to
agree the
licensing um conditions in column one by
tra so that's basically it thank
everybody the PO
parents not just
today and also all the like to
thank the offic both sides all the
work been critical it's been done
because it was obviously very difficult
situation and a difficult decision to
make that's it so we're going to keep
the license with those changes to the
conditions
about so I thank everybody for the
attendant
day just the very
firsta we EV
man decision you're happy that the event
management we put up compes what the
condition
says
thank you very much for
your